Modern science generates a lot of data —
amounts far beyond the ability
of humans to process on their own.
This is why scientists often
rely on computational methods
such as machine learning — a type of
artificial intelligence to crunch big data.
In fact, it's pretty commonplace today,
and is even used in applications like
Spotify and Netflix to help
predict your media preferences.
But there's a problem.
Traditional approaches to machine
learning, such as deep learning,
are focused on classification
and statistical correlation.
This makes them very useful for
recognising and comparing patterns
in things like audio or images,
but not very good at discovering
what might have generated
the patterns in the first place.
Understanding these so-called
generating mechanisms —
in other words the dynamics
of cause and effect —
is a fundamental challenge
across all scientific fields,
from decoding how a complex biological
cell arises from DNA, to figuring out
how a thunderstorm forms from differences
in air temperature and humidity.
Such tasks require abilities
such as inference or reasoning,
which most artificial
intelligences are not designed for.
To tackle these challenges, one
team of scientists are developing
a revolutionary new form
of machine learning,
which they've called causal deconvolution
by algorithmic generative models,
which basically means breaking down complicated and interconnected datasets
to look at the underlying mechanisms
or code that generate them.
It aims to find the individual underlying
algorithms that give rise to a dataset,
in a sense, treating natural phenomena as
computer programmes generating observed data.
So, we can think about this with a
visual analogy — if we have a table
with several objects on it and we lay
a cloth over it, we're presented with
a unique 3D terrain and this
represents a mass of collected data.
Some of it relates to the objects
underneath and some doesn't.
Modern machine learning — which
is based on classical statistics —
is good at identifying objects
by comparing features
such as shape to previous
examples it's been shown.
But what it can't do is tell us much about
how the objects underneath were formed.
The aim of this new methodology is to
first work out which bits of the terrain
relate to the different objects —
this is the deconvolution part —
and then to identify the objects by
looking at how they might be generated.
This is done by testing lots of possible coffee cup,
hat or book generating algorithms,
and looking at how these could
influence the tablecloth arrangement.
So unlike traditional machine learning,
it attempts to infer how the objects
might have been generated
to match the observed data.
But this isn't just intended to
work on imaginary dinosaurs.
It's hoped that it can be applied to
help scientists unravel the dynamics
of cause and effect in fields such
as genetics and cell biology —
for example, in understanding the complicated
gene interactions that give rise to cancer —
and that's because this methodology
moves away from classification
and towards questions of causation,
providing insights and models
to help us understand the underlying
mechanisms behind observed data.
So, as machine intelligence continues
to develop, researchers may become
increasingly reliant on AIs which think less
like machines and more like scientists.